we all got some sad news um as you know
and as everyone's been talking about
larry king uh
passed away uh over the weekend
and um i want to take a minute here at
the top of the show
to talk about larry because of course
everyone knows him as this consummate
interviewer
this legendary broadcaster he talked to
everyone uh just a a giant
in the talk show industry but
on a more personal note we had an
interesting relationship
with larry here at this show for many
years
for some reason we don't know why he
felt very comfortable coming to us
and um letting his comedy
side come out and it really started
almost from the very beginning i mean
when our show first went on the air
i think in 93 or 94 larry came on
and uh he loved to
kind of try jokes out and comedy out
with us
and that relationship started and then
it just
kept going yeah and i think for
27 28 years larry would come on our show
and we'd have a weird idea and he'd say
love it yeah i want to do it right and
it was fantastic
yeah like hey larry will you climb up in
the rafters
sure no problem yeah i'll do a show from
the rafters
rafters and um you know as time went on
we we kept thinking of sillier and
sillier things and would think
well larry probably doesn't want to do
this he's such an esteemed broadcaster
and
and i i just i love him for it he would
always say sounds funny i'll do it and
he'd show up and we'd
we'd put him in a costume we'd pitch him
these crazy ideas and he'd say
he liked to make people laugh he really
did it was something that i think gave
him a lot of joy
and he was good at it he was really
funny no he was
he was exactly what you would want larry
king to be
and then a little bit more like he was
like nicer than he had to be
and realer than he had to be yeah and a
an amazing listener to everybody he
talked to
you know yeah and so we wanted to um
we wanted to take the top of the show
today and just share
uh some of our favorite moments with
larry king
over the last uh three decades i do
listen to other people but i always end
up talking about myself
at length on the show and ultimately
making it all about me you're saying
that's probably a mistake
well it might keep it might keep you on
late
yeah you'll attend
i think the other key to a good
interview is uh keep it short thank you
for being here
you want an example of a bad interview
yeah okay okay my guest tonight is conan
o'brien conan's just written a new book
called conan o'brien's massachusetts
you right about cape cod yeah it's one
of my favorite places cape
cod i love it cave i've had a lot of
adventures on cape new a girl there once
sadie emerson owned a bar do you know
what sadie emerson i actually do i
[Applause]
thought
and stick around for more with the
wolverine
right after the break i am
i'm a lifetime heterosexual all my life
nothing again i got nothing against
gabriel i'm just
serious that's okay fine no no
man in my whole life has ever kissed me
on the lips
ever that's right alan brando kiss me
that's what i got no man has ever kissed
me so that's fine
[Applause]
i'll tell you why okay i've been
thinking about them ever since
larry king will lose his endorsement
deal with welch's grape juice
when it's revealed king hasn't had juice
in his grapes for over 20 years
[Music]
i larry king will call conan o'brien and
ask him to appear on my show as
man of the year o'brien will arrive at
the designated time
only to find an empty studio i will be
sitting at home
laughing my [ __ ]
this is fish oil a product i used to get
pains in my joints i get up in the
morning i don't get them anymore
this is from new zealand and i'm going
to give you put it on your knee would
you put it on the joint what do you know
just take their little pills just take
them take them
conan take that you'll find when someone
comes up to you and says eat these pills
eat them take them with water you got
water in there yes i got water well take
some
yeah it's never a mistake to take
stranger pills i know
so your rules are during the interview
listen and then
sell fish oil
i get a great idea we're gonna do a show
okay i'm gonna have both of you on
together oh that'd be nice and we'll
talk to a star
and a sidekick okay star
sidekick what exactly does he do
you want to know what i do this is what
i do
i have sheets and pillowcases who knew
i had larry i have sheets in pillowcases
they made a brand for me me and shawn is
called
i thought you were just bragging that
you had sheets and pillowcases
[Laughter]
i got socks yeah i got towels plates
spoons forks
why do i come here i don't know what are
you guys doing on top of them aren't we
supposed to get it yeah we're supposed
to get inside andy's right
yeah andy yes i love you
i love it
go to sleeplikeaking.com okay
okay i have a really weird job all right
live from 30 feet above me larry king
larry
hey conan uh steve from grover falls
minnesota
you're on with larry king hi larry great
show tonight
okay larry i'm sorry but you think you
could turn the volume down a little i'm
cool with you doing a show
trust me i've never seen your legs
before
[Laughter]
larry who are you talking to there sorry
caller one of my assistants
she sounds really cute hey all right
and i loved it i loved going fast i
loved um being in the trees and doing
all these things and um
i remember one day i saw my my brother
picked up snowboarding and
it's like go ahead he can't stand it
no i can't stand no i he cares no it's
your show larry go ahead
you want me to go over there no no i'm
here for you anytime you want to drop by
and uh we can stare into each other's
eyes on television conan
huh i never thought
you have some of my favorite tweets i
sit down on sunday nights and i stream
out these thoughts i don't type them out
my wife sends them out numbers i give
them to her wait you just lie there
and you shout things
celery is underrated
corn cob is a good name for a horse
is this this you're just sitting there
shouting no no no larry again we love
you did not come here to be humiliated
[Applause]
larry you have said that you plan to be
cryogenically
frozen so in other words you put me in
the ground or you
burn me up with that's you don't want
that
i want to have a f i'm jewish we gotta
have hope
i gotta if i i have a fragment of hope
my
wife is oh i thought you were saying you
want to be frozen at this size
i want to be made real small and then
frozen
put in someone's drink my wife
[Laughter]
why do i come here i don't my
what you just want to you just want to
have yet another tv show
what it is 30 years from now you come
cracking out of the ice and go
it's larry king alive
that's what you are the medical ethicist
zeke emanuel states that he hopes he
dies at age 75.
living past 75 is great there's plenty
to do
i'm constantly calling up the discovery
channel saying hey
that's not how dinosaurs walked
and another thing by the way zeke
i knew the guy you were named after the
prophet ezekiel
he was an [ __ ] too
[Music]
if i was past my prime would i be able
to do this
every night
you will be missed larry thank you so
much for your friendship
and for all the laughter